after departing from the twins REO comes
across a small convoy of the Lannister
soldiers who were sent to keep the peace
in the Riverlands voinovich gains her
attention with a song for all of you
that didn't read the books a song that
was sang by ed sheeran who appeared in
cameo as a Lancer soldier is actually
made by a singer named Simon silver
tongue in the book Simon finds out that
Tyrion and cher lovers and attempts to
blackmail Tyrion threatening that he
will reveal the truth to Cersei and
Timon Simon even wrote already mentioned
song hands of gold about those two
lovers while Tyrion was willing to pay
Simon a large amount of money to keep
his mouth shut
Simon demanded more and more which
eventually resulted with theory on
ordering Simon's death which Brown
carried out however as I was saying aria
came across a small convoy of Lannister
soldiers and agreed upon request to join
them at their fire
whereupon shills accepted their offer of
food and drinks as Arya was engaging in
small talk with them at some point she
revealed that she is heading for King's
Landing and is planning on killing Queen
Cersei which was taken as a joke by
Lannister soldiers unaware that this is
her true intention as soon as season
premiere ended many fans have been
wondering if our evil truly go to King's
Landing rather than home to Winterfell
many fans have been wondering whether or
not her arrival he'll sirs in the
following episodes let me first let's
say that it should not be surprising
that arias heading south rather than
north even though she told to jaqen
H'ghar herself that she is heading home
a girl is a stock of windfall and I'm
going home or is unaware that her
siblings retook Winterfell and therefore
as I already said are you heading south
to take off another name from her kill
list is not surprising however this
might change in the variable Yepez old
as I believe Arya will learn of
everything which has actually kind of
been confirmed by AJ itself
recently HBO has officially released a
batch of photos from the second episode
titled Stormborn and it has revealed our
is next stop on her journey to the
capital which is the Inn at the
crossroads
if you're wondering how am I so sure
that our is that popular stop for
travellers on the Kings Road in this
particular photo well beside a fact that
it lies at the meeting point of major
roads which runs north/south and
east/west
but most importantly runs to Kingsley
also if you take a look on the previous
scenes that included the in it's
definitely stay to say that re Stars
location in this photo is Dean while
Dean lies at the meeting point of
multiple roads which runs to multiple
locations in my opinion are a stark in
this photo is living Dean for Winterfell
rather than for King's Landing I know
that this might sound surprising at
first since Sara said herself in
previous episode that she's heading to
the capital to kill the Queen but give
me a few moments to explain my thoughts
now that we know that Arya will stop at
the inn on her way south it's also easy
to assume that she will have her union
with her old friend hood PI who works
over there however once hot pie and Arya
reunite there's a high possibility that
their conversation will reveal something
to Arya which would lead her to go home
instead of King's Landing there's a high
possibility that hot pie will reveal to
her that her siblings retook Winterfell
and the Jon Snow is being proclaimed as
the king in the north which will most
certainly result vitória heading home
you're most likely wondering how will
hot pie no such thing while it's
actually pretty simple hot pies working
at the crossroad scene a popular stop
for travelers on Kings Road which is
being visited by dozens or even hundreds
of people on daily basis from ordinary
people to the knights and make no
mistake there have certainly been
floating around a few words regarding
the fall of house Bolton and the raise
of House Stark well there's a high
possibility that our union between Arya
and hot pie will result Victoria's
decision to finally go home and reunite
with her siblings there's one more
possibility that would probably result
with the same outcome as I said in
breakdown of the official preview for
the second episode our reveal also
reunited with her direwolf Nymeria well
I said that arias direwolf will most
likely reunite Victoria by saving her
life
there's also high possibility that this
same reunion will lead to the full stark
reunion once Arya Stark finds out that
her family retook Winterfell whether it
will be from her friend hot pie or
someone else it's definitely not out of
the realm of possibilities that Tara
might still want to go to the capital
and kill the Queen as she probably sees
Cersei as a huge threat for her family
her union with her dire wolf on the
other hand might change her intentions
upon reuniting with Namira who is
probably the leader of a pack as she's
in the books or you might realize that
she has to reunite with her family with
the
rather than being on her own rather than
being the lone wolf in order to survive
and in order to protect her family to
sum it up upon reuniting with hot pie
and Namira
arrival most likely find out that her
siblings retook Winterfell while she
also might figure out that the lone wolf
dies but the pack survives therefore
both of these reunions that Arya will
have in the following episode will
resulted her changing her road and
heading north to Winterfell rather than
south to King's Landing we can expect to
see a full house stark reunion very soon
and the same reunion will not end up
well for Littlefinger who will try to
manipulate the stark sisters in town
fighting each other but will eventually
get manipulated himself by sense and
killed by Arya in this video I will
provide an answer on a very common
question after the season premiere which
is what did the Hound see in the flames
in the season premiere we find
Brotherhood without banners accompanied
with Center Clegane heading north
through the Riverlands they come across
a format which sender recognize it as
the forum he and Arya stayed a few years
earlier and later discovers that both
the farmer and his daughter died a long
time ago a bit later Thoris managed to
convince ander to come closer to fire
and look into the flames to our surprise
the Hound did see a vision to be exact
he saw the wall eastwatch-by-the-sea a
mountain and the thousands of dead
marching eyes a wall of ice
the wall
but us it's where the wall meets the sea
there's a castle there
there's our Mountain
looks like an arrowhead the data
marching past
thousands of them
as I said Center saw
eastwatch-by-the-sea a castle and port
located at the far eastern and the wall
where the ball drops into an inlet of
the Shivering sea called Bay of seals
Eastwatch is one of only three main
castles left on the wall along with
Castle black and the shed of tower
earlier in the season premier Johnson's
tormund and wildlings to fortify the
same castle as it is the castle closes
to hardhome where the night's king was
last seen taking into account that not
only that Center saw Eastwatch in a
vision a Jon Snow also sent us surviving
free fault warriors two men the same
castle it is it assumed that this castle
will play an important role in the
upcoming battle between the living and
the dead part of a vision in which the
Hound is a mountain that looks like an
arrowhead might be referring to several
different things but it's most likely
foreshadowing the upcoming battle that
might take place on that same Mountain
HBO's official Game of Thrones season 7
premiere recap has revealed that there
is a line of dialogue from centre's
vision which was cut from the final edit
of the episode there's one sentence they
decided not to place in the final edit
and it says the waves are frozen
this sentence might indicate how exactly
the dead are marching past so perhaps it
was cut from the actual episode to avoid
giving away too much if the night king
truly is able to freeze the Oceaneer
eastwatch-by-the-sea then he and his
army would be able to just walk around
the wall and invade the Seven Kingdoms
if the night king is able to do so then
the whole purpose of the wall and
Night's Watch doesn't make sense as it
would not be able to protect the Seven
Kingdoms from threats beyond their
northern border while I highly doubt the
night king is able to freeze seas I also
would not be very surprised if he is
able to do so as it might have been
foreshadowed back in the second season
stars will bleed
we need to stop her the cold breath of
winter will freeze the Seas
not no and the dead shall rise in the
north
as I can hear in the season 2 premiere
Melisandre said the line that seems to
be fitting perfectly with Sanders line
that was cut from the actual episode now
Sandra said the cold breath of winter
will freeze the Seas well Sandra perhaps
for Cheryl how exactly will the night
king invade Seven Kingdoms
or centers line that was cut from the
final edit on the other hand was either
considered as a huge spoiler or just
another unnecessary line and as always
let me know your opinion about all of
this in the comment section down below
I'm curious what your thoughts are about
Arya Stark and her reunion in the
following episode as well as about the
Hound and his vision I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one